in advance of an expected vote to
impeach the US president in the House of
Representatives Donald Trump slammed the
case against him the whole impeachment
thing is a hoax
we look forward to getting onto the
Senate we're not entitled to lawyers
were not entitled to witnesses were not
entitled to anything in the house it's a
total sham those Oval Office statements
echoed the sentiments of a six-page
letter on official letterhead the Trump
sent to Democratic House Speaker Nancy
Pelosi accusing her of conducting an
illegal partisan coup Trump goes on to
say by proceeding with you're invalid
impeachment you are violating your oath
of office you are breaking your
allegiance to the Constitution and you
are declaring open war on American
democracy President Trump is expected to
be impeached in the house on two
articles abuse of power and obstruction
of Congress Trump says he wrote his
letter to the House Speaker to create a
permanent record of his thoughts on the
historic vote Trump maintains he
committed no wrongdoing when last July
in a phone call he asked the Ukrainian
president for a favor to help unearth
corruption involving his political rival
former Vice President Joe Biden
we must act with a sense of urgency to
protect our democracy on Capitol Hill as
Democrats battled opposition Republicans
over the terms of the impending
impeachment vote Democrats defended
their desire to impeach Trump arguing
it's the only way to preserve the
integrity of the upcoming 2020
presidential vote given that an
unrepentant president considers his
behavior perfect given that he thinks
the Constitution empowers him to do
whatever he wants
given that he and his team are still
awaiting president zalenski statement
about investigating Joe Biden we can
only ask what the 2020 election will be
like or indeed what any future election
in America will be like if we just let
this misconduct go but in his letter
Trump disputed Democrats motives writing
as you know very well this impeachment
drive has nothing to do with Ukraine
or the totally appropriate conversation
I had with its new president it only has
to do with your attempt to undo the
election of 2016 and steal the election
of 2020 and despite efforts by the White
House to block witness testimony during
the impeachment inquiry Trump has
accused Democrats of denying him due
process likening his treatment to the
Salem witch trials of the 1600s were
those falsely accused of witchcraft were
executed it's a message that seems
geared to trump supporters a rallying
cry Trump's letter says could propel him
to re-election Kimberly Hellcat al
Jazeera the White House